there's much anger and emotion to be
found following Friday's shooting
Talking Heads on Sundays shows
entertainers at events you're not gonna
fix it by taking away the rights of
law-abiding citizens you've got to fix
it in a way that hardens to place
sufficiently if that means five metal
detectors getting in and out of a high
school you get five metal detectors have
you guys done enough in the south course
not of course not but it's like every
other issue the American people are
united the way the search for the never
pass it's a three-letter word it's the
NRA you must control your guns at home
and be sure they're locked up at number
two Jake we need to get down to one or
two entrances into our schools we need
armed teachers trained of course why
don't we not do it one of signs why
won't we do a moment of action why don't
we do moment of change why don't we
change what's happening now every
location where these opinions were
offered was well protected because
someone cared enough to protect those
people they cared enough to pay for it
so again this is a laurel and yanny
moment some look at Friday and hear too
many guns others hear we need more armed
personnel people here are other factors
to blame as well for example a pop
culture that glorifies violence like
video games social networks that expose
status inequalities a generation dreamt
in medic drenched in medications
bullying and nihilism it's natural to
seek causes after a ghastly event the
meanwhile according to recent research
shootings involving students have been
declining since the 90s it's weird
because of anything it feels like the
opposite is the case it leaves you
scratching your head without alleviating
any pain for the victims families so the
only thing certain is uncertainty except
when it comes to us the media it's been
reported that the killer spared some
victims hoping they tell his side of the
story so where would that story be told
here by us as long as we do our part to
tell the story with ceaseless coverage
featuring the cowards face and name
these events will continue it's the
simplest cause and effect if someone
performs an act for the sake of infamy
and you provide him that infamy mission
accomplished and it's a mission that
leads ultimately to another
Keiji that yeah when you see the facts
and you hear that mass shootings are in
decline I can understand why that
wouldn't matter because if you replace
the mass shootings with terror it
wouldn't matter to me I would go like I
you still must be vigilant I don't
believe but the thing is it's these
statistics fly in the face of what we
emotionally believe so true because when
you get that it's like an almost it's an
emotional saturation that's palpable
that you feel it and remember the day
with the last shooting we were all just
sitting here you just can't you feel
heavy with the emotion the grief of it
when you see that these happen and it
seems almost like in rapid succession
okay but you make such a good point
people are saying these things are well
protected because someone's caring to
put the money in and the time to make
sure that they are safe what is going on
I feel the frustration of the parents
that have had children that have been
injured or maimed or killed because why
is it that even one more school shooting
is acceptable as a casualty or
collateral damage etc why can't you just
it's not hard to do I would have dogs at
the schools I would have one point of
entry so that if there's somebody coming
in and there's an attacker you can just
bottle cap them in and secure and
predict prevent a digital off of life
throughout the school you've got to
prevent them from being able to go in
deeper into the school and having more
targets right and if you have a metal
detector
so what I'd rather have my son go to
school okay through a metal detector and
maybe have someone there you're armed
with the guard and dogs there because I
know that he's gonna come home that
night yeah so that's how you have to put
it yes it's not pleasant but it's
reality and you have to deal with it
it's like not treating a disease being
told you have cancer and refusing to
take a medication for it yeah you don't
want
there was a symbolic suggestion by I by
Obama's former Secretary of Education
Arne Duncan I think we might have a
tweet up there but basically the gist of
the tweet is students should not go to
school until gun laws are changed that
would keep them safe and he believes
this is a brilliant and tragically
necessary idea do you think this is more
or less just kind of a powerful message
but it's not practical in any way like
kids just not going to school
well it's not he I think he even said if
it's not then on a large scale yeah
really doesn't work but if it is done on
a large scale it's much like what we saw
after the events in parkland where the
voice and the power of young people
saying I don't feel safe in my school
mom and dad really does help to I think
raise some people and get people to say
hey we have to think about the fact that
children our children our future should
be protected I would say this in
response to Kimberly I think that that
school in Texas was given an award for
being a hardened target and Greg and
I've been back and forth on this but we
know that many of sites where there have
been shootings there were armed guards
the key for me here is there were three
right no I think there's more than that
but the point that I we have metal
detectors and no make no that's one
point of it but my point is look we're
all looking for everything people talk
about folks with mental health issues
they talk about you know oh this guy is
a bad guy he was a gang member whatever
or he had a grudge or he was stalking
the fact there's just too many guns in
the country then you say oh but now in
media places or government offices we
use pay to protect people well why don't
we say hey you know as Americans boy
more than one gun for every person and
this kid gets his dad's guns over the
guy in Connecticut but one yoke is mom's
long you were going to you were going so
forward to practical solutions and then
you go back to the too many guns think
that's where you start well you mean
it's impractical to two fractions no
it's impractical to say when you just
say there's too many guns that is a
blanket statement that doesn't apply
like those imagine if you didn't go to
school because there's too many guns
right you will never go to school again
yeah yeah exactly
like the practical all the things that
Kimberly suggested let's just say that
maybe if there was a way to compromise
what one is suggesting is arse to many
guns we got to get rid of the guns but
in the meantime yeah if you want your
children to be safe as schools all the
things that Kimberly laid out would make
sense exactly and there aren't ways to
tag civilly tag people who are unstable
but by teachers and officials which is a
is actually taking guns away but Jesse
yeah I mean a lot of deadly school
shootings have happened in the last 10
years that's just the truth but the
amount of guns in this country hasn't
quadrupled it's been relatively steady
and they
hasn't been a massive deregulation of
gun laws so what has changed I think
Greg you're right there's a Columbine
cap copycat situation there's the rise
of social media and the iPhone there's
the over prescription of psychiatric
drugs to teens we got the promise
program cyberbullying where they're you
know not trying to criminalize criminal
kids so it look at the polls the polls
say 57% of this country think it's a
mental health issue only 20 or so
percent believe it's a gun control issue
and most people do want stricter gun
control but you know the two things they
want they want number one stricter
background checks and number two more
money spent on mental health screenings
so to demonize the NRA is a political
solution but it's not a practical
solution because NRA members aren't mass
shooters they usually neutralize mass
shooters and Planned Parenthood and the
labor unions they spend much more money
lobbying than does the NRA and if the
Democrats really wanted to do something
about gun control they had the house in
the Senate for two years under Obama
they didn't do it in the cities that
have the strictest gun control laws
usually run by Democrat mayors have very
high rates of why don't they're
Republicans then take a step from
everybody at this table and say hey you
know what we agree universal background
checks we're gonna do better on
background checks we're gonna not allow
people to yell at abide that would've
prevented this though yeah no no the
idea is not you can't say you can always
it wouldn't have prevented this one
prick but we can do better we also solve
information all the information that we
have coming in on a student put it all
together in a database